saïd rigoler rose bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france nouveau cycle de
négociations donc au qatar entre le
gouvernement afghan et les talibans les
talibans qui par la voix de leur chef se
dit ce matin favorable un règlement
politique
est ce envisageable selon vous alors que
sur le terrain il mène tambour battant
leurs offensives déclarations de la
délégation name qui évoque le fait que
la priorité des talibans seraient
aujourd'hui nous reste sous le point par
le dialogue
alors évidemment c'est une déclaration
suscite perplexité
alors la mesure où il ya une stratégie
en fait à double détente de la part des
éléments c'est à la fois cherché à
imposer un règlement pacifique à leur
profit entre guillemets et puis
maintenir la pression des armes
donc c'est une grande confusion qui
reste sur le terrain mais effectivement
la pression talibane est forte et ils
veulent profiter
finalement de tous les espaces qui leur
sont offertes à perdre si terre pour
afficher crédibilité politique surtout à
l'international
récemment saga lavrov le chef de la
diplomatie russe a accusé les états unis
d'avoir engendré un risque sécuritaire
dans la région avec le retrait des
troupes militaires américaines est ce
que vous partagez stasi mais ça c'est le
ojeda ce sont les éléments de langage de
moscou effectivement puisqu'il ya un
retrait en les années les les principaux
pays alentour ce soit là aussi les nachi
les nôtres pakistan notamment également
ont considéré que finalement la présence
des occidentaux est en général et
américaine en particulier était un
élément l'hystérisation et puis à partir
du moment où les américains décident à
retrait rapide et bien il ya une
perplexité des autres qui considère que
c'est un double ko donc en réalité
la présence des occidentaux étaient
aussi quelque chose qui permettait alors
aux adversaires de justement de
stigmatiser une présence qui par
ailleurs était elle était quand même
relativement stabilisée à tresser qui
avait certains de ses acteurs comme la
chine
et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la chine
est très embarrassé justement pas le
vide qui est créé par ce retrait la
russie qui craint également l'extension
des combats au delà des frontières de
l'afghanistan une menace qui est réel
selon vous oui il ya une vraie
inquiétude qui est partagée d'ailleurs
par tous les pays et dimitrov
d'ailleurs le tadjikistan a mobilisé
près de vermine réservistes pour
sécurité sécuriser la frontière après
justement là la prise de contrôle par
les talibans de ce morceau frontière
avec le tadjikistan les îles il faudra
aussi qu'il est pas très important de la
russie et au tadjikistan bouquet une
inquiétude sourde inquiets qui est
patente aujourd'hui qui est partagé à
entendre des pays et qui alimente
d'ailleurs le retrait des communautés
étrangères succession paix et puis la
fermeture d'ailleurs d'ambassadeurs de
pays où arrivent les i c'est dire qu'il
ya un sentiment de patrick est qui et
qui est alimenté par aussi par les
effets ne date au sein de la part des
cas dûment parce que quand ils ne
mentionnent leur pension et pense
évidemment pas le cas aucune des grandes
villes mais tomber à l'instant même s'il
ya une gigue asphyxie telle il est
d'ailleurs on peut penser que les offres
supposé de de sessegnon qu'il aurait
déformé par les dépenses aussi là pour
pérenniser en fait des gains sur le
terrain avec l'idée que la prise des
bulls a hobo publique et que la maîtrise
des autres mois quel rôle jouent les
autres pays voisins l'iran le
turkménistan ou encore le pas question
c'est que kaboul accuse l'armée
pakistanaise de fournir un soutien
aérien aux talibans dans certaines zones
ce que dément islamabad
oui si l'accusation d'amour là savaient
qu'ils étaient lorsqu'un chef 10h02
des renseignements a manqué deux
vice-présidents qui a mentionné
effectivement lusage le recours à
l'aviation au profit des talibans sur la
frontière de la ligue durant ce délai
entre le la bédéiste ont attaqué ce
temps le jus n'est pas question que
j'aurai des troubles il est de notoriété
publique que des pakistanais ont soutenu
le manière ou l'autre effectivement la
mouvance talibane
par ailleurs d'autres pays sont inquiets
liant effectivement constate que la
pression est très forte et liant à
nouveau j'ai quand même temps dans la
province de viraat avec d'anciens chefs
de guerre comme ellis madrane la chine a
dit qu' elle souhaitait qu'une
stabilisation justement la situation et
imprimantes avec les talibans dont
convoi car il ya un jeu de grandes
manoeuvres qui se fait à l'échelle
régionale pour bat pour que chacun en
tire profit d'une situation qui est
extrêmement chaotique
la dernière question on parle beaucoup
des talibans des forces gouvernementales
on oublie peut-être la population civile
qui est aujourd'hui a pris en étau on
l'a dit des milliers de personnes sont
en train de de fuir l'afghanistan qui a
d'ailleurs demandé à l'europe de ne pas
fermer ses frontières en tout cas
qu'elle ne elle n'allait pas accepté le
renvoi de deux migrants dans son pays
oui il ya nombre de déplacés qui est de
plus en plus importants et ses reflets
de cette situation chaos qui prévaut sur
le terrain notamment dans les zones
rurales avec un afflux vers les villes
qui sont censés être plus sécurisé même
s'il reste ou pas des attentats et puis
il ya la question migratoire qui va à
l'extérieur pas seulement en termes de
déplacés effectivement en termes de
réfugiés potentiels
d'où la déclaration qui a été lancé à
l'adresse des européens qui craignent a
certainement en situation la syrienne
comme il y avait eu effectivement 2016
parce que beaucoup de gars de plus en
plus d'ailleurs de d'abord qui sont
signalés dans les plus libres et war à
destination de l'europe
ces derniers mois merci beaucoup en tout
cas david rigoulet roze d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
orient stratégique